Mad Catz the financial fugitive is
stopped at a bank in Columbia South
Carolina he was at the teller and the
cops came in and handcuffed him and said
come with me and he was like oh crap I'm
freaking out
Cox goes downtown to the sheriff's
department
they let him drive his car and that's
when he called me because you made this
is bad it's like they're here they pick
me up at this point they don't know he's
Matthew Cox they think he's Gary
Sullivan the homeless person Cox steals
the identity of a street person and
takes out one this is where she says I'm
not bailing you out [ __ ] you you say
[ __ ] you but yes he's like I do not give
two million dollars worth of loans on a
house worth about $200,000 at the bank
Cox is trying to withdraw some of his
fraudulent proceeds so they took him
into a room and he talked his way out of
it he told the guy it's a I have a 2nd
and 3rd on my home that's that's illegal
I convinced him that there's nothing
illegal about taking out multiple loans
in the same house when the Richland
County Sheriff's Department runs a
criminal history for Gary Sullivan they
see no warrants for his arrest the local
police at this point usually wouldn't
make an immediate arrest unless someone
was wanted and of course they ran the
identity that cops was using but that
person was not wanted Gary Sullivan was
not wanted the police in Columbia had
him dead to rights but they didn't have
the paperwork and they weren't certain
who they were dealing with and he talked
his way out of the situation and was
gone
in Colombia Bridget Brown gets an e that
[ __ ] on a podcast to give his side of
the story call from the Secret Service
she and her husband go back to their
home I've talked to a few Gary Sullivan
of course is long gone on the kitchen
countertop was a fax machine on it was
just tons of spilling out of mortgage
applications for home equity loans these
were just some examples of the infamous
loan applications that we found in her
house that's where he had forged our
names that he had paid us off and wanted
to take the money and run in essence the
Browns now have seven mortgages on their
home it will take them more than a year
to clear the title Thaksin hawk take
their 1.2 million and flee to Houston
but life is Bonnie and Clyde is losing
its appeal we used to fight all the time
we screaming Elliot at that time look
how dramatic these camera angles are can
you appreciate this b-roll they went out
of their way to go to a motel room [ __ ]
it all up and then shoot these insane
camera and we we didn't live in home I
was in Houston for less than 24 hours
she had moved there first
she were into the place and in a post
apartments like [ __ ] way up and like
the 20th floor or something I mean he
had an amazing apartment house in in not
a pin house but whatever way it was up
there in in Houston I went there right
after I got caught we get into this huge
[ __ ] argument she gives me a hundred
thousand dollars out of like six hundred
thousand dollars she gives me like a
hundred grand I take the [ __ ] on the
grand I take off I go back to Charlotte
to pick up my car Charlotte North
Carolina that's where I almost get
grabbed by the [ __ ] us at USF
Marshalls man I told you this at the
Starbucks yeah but yeah so I was every
was there for there may sound like we
hung out there
hang out there and on top of that all
this b-roll is [ __ ] that's not the
[ __ ] that's our hotel room sells it man
it really is so it makes good for a good
TV pretty [ __ ] terrible be rola but I
guess this was without and [ __ ] yeah
well they don't sophisticated like you
are no I'm not sophisticated I guess the
stylist has changed yeah I probably do
that better be so why if she had six on
our grand why would you even accept only
taking a hundred grant and giving her a
half a million dollars and she [ __ ]
she was cuz she had a one she was like
if you like she'd want to give me
anything but she want to give me like
ten grand
so I'm arguing and she finally said look
I'll give you $100,000 I was saying
split the money she's saying ten grand
I can't believe in you I can't believe
you even well first except because she
was saying about accepting half here's
what she's saying she's saying that if I
don't we don't we have to you are gonna
be okay with this because if you cuz I
was saying look I'll take all the
[ __ ] money if you don't split it
you'll have nothing she owes and where
you gonna go with that she was you're
using a driver's license that they
already know they're looking for this
guy Gary Sullivan was all the drivers
license I only one I had there like you
got oh I had a Michael Eckert one too so
they know Mike who Michael Eckert is by
now - they're like you're driving a you
you're driving a Ryder truck in the name
of a guy that they're going to be
looking for because if you take all the
money I'll call the police
and they'll be looking for that Ryder
truck in his name um how many miles five
hundred a thousand miles away from a
couple thousand miles away from
Charlotte North Carolina I've got to go
back there to get my car which is also
in the name of a guy they're looking for
but at least it's not the Ryder truck oh
you know all my fake IDs when I drove
the Ryder truck there to move my
apartment there all my stuff because we
lived in two separate houses at this
point we she had her own [ __ ]
apartment I had my own apartment she had
moved her apartment to Houston so now
I'm picking up packing up my stuff and
moving it we put all my stuff in a
storage unit along with my IDs so I
couldn't even go and say [ __ ] you and
grab all my ID all this all my IDs that
I had collected there in her storage
unit so I'm just [ __ ] I've got two IDs
with me that
they're looking for in a writer truck so
we're not we're arguing and I'm she's
I'm saying I'll take all the money and
she's saying and what were you gonna go
in the writer truck they're looking for
even if you have all the [ __ ] money
she's like I'll make one call here's the
thing if I was this brutal angry
manipulative guy I'd have just beaten
her ass or something choked her to death
or something instead I'm sitting there
like practically begging her you got to
give me something what are you I can't
leave with 10 grand what am I gonna but
she didn't have a powerful argument
which was this she said look I can't do
what you do you'll take the hundred
thousand you'll turn it into a couple
million very quickly I'm gonna have to
live off this money for the rest of my
life and she was right she wasn't she
wasn't she's not a con she's not a
grifter she's not gonna be able to
survive mm-hmm I didn't think she'd be
able to go very long at all I was amazed
she lasted a year and I remember
thinking she's right I'll take the money
I'll make a bunch more money and I did
very quickly I had a few million dollars
very quickly make sense so I just
grabbed the money and left my biggest
problem is I'm driving I got no ID I
cannot get pulled over
Rebecca hasn't seen her son in more than
a year that's not true that's [ __ ] up
that's not true why because when we went
to Vegas we saw her son really we
stopped we gave her son money we gave
her [ __ ] parents money we gave her
ex-husband money we gave everybody money
and by the way when they catch her she
didn't give him all the money she's got
a whole bunch of money she told me that
she had [ __ ] money she had left the
money was with the guy she's locked in
banging she told me all the told me what
really happened so I'm like damn oh she
[ __ ] she did pretty good anyway but
yeah she had seen her son we went there
and and she she saw her son like I like
hung out and she saw her son for like
half a day like six or seven hours then
she called me I picked her up then we
bought a bunch of [ __ ] presents and
gifts she left him money she left the
husband I actually gave the ex-husband
money I actually met him at his job 30
grand
yeah we she gave her
family money she gave her her son was
actually staying with her mother like we
were just happened to drive by her mom's
ex-husband 30 grand cuz you know if he's
taking care of the kid she's not like
she's a mother was taking care of the
kid and you just said she was the kid
was staying with him for the weekend
brother they don't live like now like a
couple miles he was staying from
grandmother's house for the weekend
there okay so so we happen to dweep
she's like oh that's drive by my mom's
house and we're driving by the mother's
house she's like holy SH she's like oh
my god there's Bryce he's playing in the
front yard and I was like [ __ ] you
wanted to see him like her do you want
to stop here because we were gonna go
buy the husband's house to see him to
see him cuz I had already dropped off
money at the husband's mmm so I was like
I told the husband he gave me his phone
number and everything I was gonna we
were gonna set up a time and I was like
[ __ ] if you want to see Bryce you do it
right now
this guy's not getting off work for like
[ __ ] six or eight hours we do it
right now and she's like oh it's perfect
because nobody expects it he's there so
I pull over I let her out she walks in
she calls me and says I'm good you can
go I go down the street I hang out for
like five or six hours until eventually
she calls because we ever like hour or
so eventually she calls me says okay I'm
ready I go by I pick her up then we
ended up meeting the husband again we
give him a bunch if we buy a bunch of
toys and I mean you know look it's a
shitty thing but it's like the least you
can do like her son's like look I want
this I want this I want this a we go we
spend a couple grand and buy him all
these toys and all this stuff he wants
come back we drop it off with the
[ __ ] husband with the ex-husband you
know I mean it's it's a shitty situation
but the whole I hadn't seen my hunt my
son and this look that's not sure and
then there's the pressure from the
Secret Service Cox Google's himself
constantly he knows the Secret Service
is working with the media to get their
faces in front of as many people as
possible
Rebecca Hogg can't stand the heat we're
on TV this US Secret Service was doing a
press conference about us they had done
our pictures and warrant pictures and I
just freaked out I'm like no we got to
leave we have to leave this is you know
this is we're too close they're gonna
find us we got to go
she was definitely gonna get us call I
mean that's what I was thinking she was
having a meltdown I mean she really was
melting down as he was she was coming
apart one morning in March of 2005
Rebecca takes a shower not through 24
hours then we had an argument he to
steal away he takes all the cash but
leaves behind all his cell phones that's
true any way that I could get a hold of
him he left and I was just like what and
so I've expected okay he's gonna come
back he's just mad he's gonna come back
and well he never came back
she says you took all the money she let
keep in mind look that that is basically
see how it's that she's that that slob
whatever is going on there that's
basically how she um so that was
actually a good b-roll so out to the
b-roll team at NBC so first of all she
didn't get a job for a year so if you
didn't get a job for a year how did you
live if I took all the money [ __ ] yeah
you had five photographs so one you did
keep the money
you're also she had bought a brand new
car and a motorcycle she's paid in full
for a beauty school so she's going to
beauty school because she realizes after
a few months he ain't coming back
so she says okay she gets beaut does the
beauty school thing so how did you do
all of that with no money no it doesn't
even makes it but see like Americans
they don't even question that no of
course not and I and the Secret Service
agent Adrienne peacock she told me she's
like now I mean we we we know you left
her with money because I was like I left
her with money I mean even [ __ ] more
money yeah [ __ ] she had money and
they're like no we know she had money
they're like look she had like 30 grand
in the bank cars paid for motorcycles
paid for
she's got jewel
she's been paying [ __ ] like $2,000
I'm twenty two hundred or something like
that and rent every month this is [ __ ]
fifteen years ago
so she they like trust me we know she's
got money yeah but anyway so yeah total
[ __ ] [ __ ] weeks turn into months
and Rebecca tries to go straight she
makes up a new name Rebecca sue Hickey
and goes to work as a cocktail waitress
but someone recognizes her face we got a
phone call based on our wanted poster
that this person believed that she was
using the name Rebecca Hickey Rebecca
Hawke is arrested in Houston while
attending class at a cosmetology school
there were about five u.s. marshals that
came in to class and I was just like man
and I you know I thought they're here
for me
The Secret Service hopes Rebecca can
answer their most depressing question
where is Matt comes
she hasn't seen him or talked to him in
a year
[ __ ] is still on the run now he's in
Nashville with a new girl and a new real
estate company single mother maybe it's
not catching up with them but the con
man is about to become a victim when
American greed returns you can't get
away with that forever you're gonna get
cause I've actually met that police
officer um like I've seen her on the
show and I've seen quotes from her and
stuff I don't remember talking to her I
think she may have been the person that
called me to say hey can you meet us at
the office but
[Music]
[Laughter]